like under the impression that ken's
taking the company down and so she's
over here panic buying nutribullets and
buying a lot of krugerrands like a very
particular currency and she never even
drinks the smoothies
hey guys pete here succession is back
for season three and we got our first
episode that was titled secession it's a
table setter where not a lot happened if
you really think about it but there's
still a lot to unpack you got some good
memeage and straight up white bronco era
oj simpson callbacks complete with the
dark joke from kendall who said i never
killed anyone which is dastardly even if
he's the only one that gets it and just
real quick i have to throw out a spoiler
warning if you're not caught up then
this video won't be for you can't have
any weevils in the flower sack and with
that out of the way let's slide the
sociopolitical thermometer up the
nation's ass and take a reading let's
get into it
season 3 starts right where things were
left following kendall's press
conference at the end of season 2 where
he turned on his father on national tv
accusing him of complicity in the cruise
scandal that's threatening to see the
roys lose control of waystar royco and
he's got the documents from greg to
prove it his sliding into an empty
bathtub is a nice parallel with the
season 2 premiere where he was submerged
in a hot tub at a scandinavian rehab
this time there's no one there to look
after him and as the episode unfolds it
becomes clear that he didn't have a plan
for the aftermath of his bombshell
allegations so much so that he hadn't
considered that carolina might not jump
on his train or that the company might
lock him out of the building he's mostly
got buzzwords and nowhere to go there's
another nice nod to season 2 here the
phone call between father and son logan
calls what kendall's doing a decent move
he calls it out for what it is a play
and that does back up the idea that in
the finale when he was watching the
press conference he was proud of his
number one boy i said that not much
happens in this episode in light of the
situation no one in logan's orbit can do
anything except wait and see what he
does sure they can strategize and scheme
that's always a joy to watch but at the
end of the day he's the one with the
power and everyone else is motivated to
preserve whatever they already have in
relation to that kendall is the one
exception he decides to establish his
operation center at robba's place you
really start to see him getting high on
his own hype when he tells her that he
kind of did it for them implying that he
kind of did this all for his family the
big thing he's able to accomplish the
one thing that seems to be in his favor
he hired this new lawyer lisa arthur who
by the fact that everyone else in the
family was also trying to hire her is
obviously a name and it does sound like
a win for him and that she's there
because of what he's trying to do she
lays things out pretty plainly telling
him that this is a quite complex
situation to progress because as i
understand it you want to take down your
dad without implicating yourself and
without damaging the company to the
extent that you lose control at your
shareholder meeting the government is
going to want to talk to him and lisa
seems like the only one he might be able
to count on to be looking out for his
best interest i mean he's got greg whose
loyalty might overshadow his
incompetence but i kind of think there's
a possibility he'll just go back to work
tomorrow as he's taking these meetings
kendall is visibly intoxicated he's in
what looks like a manic state and i
think at least right now he's actually
not using coke or any other drugs he's
quite literally getting high from the
process and this really comes across in
the meeting he has with the two women
who are going to be taking over his
social media i guess their
communications people who are clearly
professional and are there with a plan
that they can't even get out because he
keeps interrupting them he's talking
about getting some bojack guys and the
lampoon kids and getting his twitter
feed going and this is the side of
kendall we've seen in the past
so what kendall was able to do was
create this situation where his father
is truly vulnerable the way that he
reacts throughout the episode makes it
clear that this is something that he's
worried about he can't even get the
president on the phone at this point
because it wouldn't look good if that
was on the white house logs and in
talking with their representative jerry
isn't able to get any kind of assurances
this has brought people over to
kendall's side at least a high-powered
lawyer in the communications team and
deep down neither one of them father or
son cares about the actual crimes that
happen during the scandal with cruises
logan decides to go on the offensive at
one point he says he's gonna go full
[ __ ] beast after brushing aside every
suggestion saying that he should
cooperate or try to make some
improvements and put a good face on it
he does realize that he's gonna have to
step back from the ceo role agreeing to
put someone else in there but it's
pretty obvious that he still wants
operational control and he's just
looking for someone to act as his puppet
the choices come down to roman schiv and
jerry roman comes so close it does seem
like his father was thinking about it
earlier in the episode he said
everything that his father wanted to
hear him say but on the phone when logan
doesn't say yes right away roman pivots
saying that he'd be willing to work
under jerry and kind of putting her
forward and that doesn't mean as soon as
he gets off the phone logan says that
roman's out and for what it's worth i do
think he was about to say yes and he
just blew it because they were friends
shib is sent to talk to lisa about
becoming logan's lawyer other than some
weird tension that comes up whenever she
tries to get her to be her personal
lawyer nothing really comes out of it
because she's already talked to kendall
that takes shibb out of the running for
the ceo which means that only jerry's
left so she eventually gets it which
interrupts romans trying to take things
to the next level with their
relationship they were in a hotel room
together and roman was really going for
it he says things like i'd lay you badly
but i'd lay you gladly and that he's
like a young fighter raw and still
hungry all of that gets put on hold
after she gets the call roman decides to
call shiv to rub it in and then she
tells her driver that she had a change
of plans which i guess is indicating
that she's gonna go try to talk to
kendall now to examine her possibilities
things come to an end with logan walking
outside of the hotel looking determined
to bring kendall down the stage is set
and we can imagine where it goes from
here the conversation between frank and
carl on the plane earlier comes to mind
when they were talking about him being
the comeback kid hard to say how the
current situation stacks up against say
the tabloid suicides when they nearly
went kablooey because of argentina the
tiananmen accommodations or that black
cloud after sally anne but logan would
have never gathered the power he has if
he wasn't a survivor knowing how his
last two attempts played out and seeing
ken's behavior in this episode the third
time going for daddy doesn't feel like
the charm i guess it's more of a
question of what he's able to scare up
on logan as he crashes and burns and as
naomi pointed out last season watching
these people melt down is the most
deeply satisfying activity on the planet
earth i guess as far as going full
[ __ ] beast is concerned the
implication is that he'll expose
kendall's involvement in the car
accident and the waiter's death this
isn't so cut and dry though logan played
an active role in covering up his son's
criminal act which is of course also a
criminal act i'm actually not sure how
he could follow through with that and i
guess we'll have to wait and see
some other things on the sidelines here
tom was mostly a fish out of water this
episode he ended up with frank and logan
and we saw that things still aren't
resolved between him and shib as they
were saying goodbye he really seemed
like he was out of his element with no
one there for him to punch down on not
much connor at all but that conversation
with willow was something in the middle
of everything else that's going on he's
still trying to figure out how to
salvage his investment in the play he's
looking into doing some marketing that
would exploit the whole hate watch angle
pushing in a ronno's cycle and
capitalizing on all the negative reviews
to bring in the hipsters and [ __ ]
i'm looking forward to seeing jerry in
the ceo role she's one of my favorite
characters to watch because she's really
good at being just as slimy as everyone
else but appearing to be otherwise
limiting our own exposure which i
imagine being the head of the company
will make a little bit more difficult
you got a feel for kenzak's wife robba
there was a pretty straight line
progression from kind of inappropriate
to just completely out of line in the
way things were happening there
especially with naomi so i imagine that
will all come to a head soon the two
year break seemed to really give the
writers some time to get the quips and
the one-liners laser focused this was a
solid episode that did a great job
picking things up after the high of the
season 2 finale so many hilarious bits
that make it one of the funniest
episodes in a show that has a lot of
them greg being pete greg a trip to
sarajevo to avoid extradition a brief
battle to be the temporary replacement
and a whole lot of potential for
shifting allegiances to keep things
lively one of the things i wonder about
with this show is how far can you
stretch the family dynamics before
things get stale so i like the idea of
shifting the focus towards the corporate
crimes because this is an area where
it's clear that no one really cares
about the victims and you can imagine
kendall playing towards that somewhat
cynically trying to differentiate
himself from his father when they're all
basically the same it seems like there's
some potential there mystery razors
reverse banjos and panic buying
cougarands and nutra bullets there's a
lot of little threads here to pull on
later and that seems like a good place
to leave things let me know in the
comments where you think things are
going and what you're hoping to see
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon